on va faire le point sur la famille
royale qui a une actualité assez chargée
et pas que des bonnes nouvelles on va en
parler dans un instant dans un instant
aussi on viendra sur complément
d'enquête France Télévision suspend la
diffusion de compléments d'enquête sur
de plusieurs compléments d'enquête
euh vous avvez des infos bien entendu
Jacques Cardon et les images de Gérard
pard en Corée du Nord auraient bien été
trafiqué euh
apparemment je mets ça bien sûr à au
conditionnel on va revenir sur un
article qui a écrit qui a été écrit dans
M le monde et l'avocat dianx sera avec
nous Jérémy Assous et sachez qu'il a de
très grosses révélations à nous faire ce
soir et je peux vous dire ça va secouer
voilà là pour un vendredi ça va secouer
sec ça sera aux alentours de 20h45 pour
le moment ça va sec couer juste au
niveau capillaire c'est KERS qui est
avec nous petit reccap sur la famille
royale depuis ce matin les Britanniques
retiennent leur souffle alors que le roi
Charles vient d'être admis dans une
clinique londonienne pour pour une
opération de la
prostate une opération qui survient
après celle de la princesse Kate qui a
subi elle une opération à l'abdomen au
sein de la même clinique une
hospitalisation de 10 à 14 jours et une
convalescence de 3 mois ces problèmes de
santé qui bousculent l'agenda de
Buckingham font aujourd'hui beaucoup
parler car l'hospitalisation surprise de
la princesse et sa long convalescence
laisse place à de nombreuses rumeurs
certains craignent même qu'elle soit
atteinte d'un cancer alors le roi
Charles à l'hôpital de foles rumeurs sur
Kate Middleton ont fait le point sur la
santé de la famille royale ce soir dans
TPMP
ber Bertrand KERS le retour que je peux
faire une petite précision déjà direct
comme ça oui j'ai grandi à la je grandis
j'ai grandi et je vis toujours en partie
à la campagne c'est-à-dire que moi petit
au milieu des chevaux des vaches des
cochons j'ai fait du tracteor oui tu
disais
je suis déjà monté à bordar c'est ça que
voulais dire j'aime beaucoup ça
ou as d'autres infos ou bien c'est
excuse-moi et donc là là là donc ce que
tu as préparé c'est ça voilà bah il a
tout dans la tête c'est ça il c'est PL
de termes un peu médicaux d'accord j'ai
jamais besoin de fiche ouais tout dans
la tête il a tout dans la tête oui ouais
fa des m on va voir ce que ça donne
vas-y que veux-tu
savoir ça ça pourquoi Kate est
hospitalisé on commence par Kate donc
bah oui Kate est hospitalisé depuis
mardi dernier nous étions le 16 le 16
euh en janvier janvier exactement on
alors on ne sait voilà elle est
hospitalisée la seule chose que nous dit
Kensington Palace c'est hospitalisation
durant 14 jours pour un
problème problème abdominal abdominal
surt abdominal et puis a pas la
pendicite mais justement on on ne sait
enfin 14 jours par que c il avait la
pindiciteou 14 jours a
fait j'ai cru qu'il allait mourir dans
une
semaine une suspension totale de ses
activités durant presque 3 mois jusqu'au
mois d'avril en tout cas ce qui veut
dire que d'blé il y a eu une très très
grande inquiétude on se dit mais c'est
quand même très très important et comme
le palais refuse de bah nous dire
précisément ce qu'elle a tous les bruits
circulent en effet et le premier des
bruits très très rapide qui a commencé à
circuler c'est est que ce serait pas une
tumeur cancéreuse que ce serait pas un
cancer donc le palais fait pas les
oiseaux jou pas les oiseaux de mauvaise
augure sur Kate a dit non ce n'est pas
un cancer en revanche les bruits
continuent quand même à circuler et ils
ne sont pas positifs puisque il
longtemps on a dit qu'il s'agissait
d'une diastase abdominale c'est un
problème que rencontre les femmes suite
à des grossess un peu pas non mais c'est
pour ça que j'ai une petite fiche j'ai
vu un médecin suite à des problèmes à
des grossesses un peu compliquées
d'autres ont parlé d'une grossesse
extrautérine mais il semblerait
maintenant que d'après les spécialistes
anglais on partirait plutôt sur une
hystérectomie alors qu'est-ce qu'une
hstérectomie c'est une ablation de
l'utérus et si cette hystérectomie là
est totale c'est une ablation de
l'utérus des S et des trompes il
semblerait qu'on parte plutôt vers ça ça
justifierait les 14 jours
d'hospitalisation et les 3 mois de
retrait ce qui veut donc dire que c'est
une grosse grosse intervention William
est presque en permanence à ses côt
calme calme parce que toi tu vas pas
nous faire nous faire un
AVC calme mon chéri euh quand est-ce
qu'elle va reprendre ses fonctions Kate
justement pas avant le mois d'avril ce
qui veut donc dire qu'ils ont d sus ils
ont dû suspendre déjà beaucoup
d'activités
dont très grand voyage prévu entre
autres en Italie en Italie où ça à Rome
il devait entre autres rencontrer le
pape le pape ah ouais le pape PAP le
pape non le
pape je croyais ancien ministre de
l'Éducation d'accord le papend d'accord
et d'autres choses alors ce qui pose
c'est quoi William pendant la
convalescence de sa femme il est à côté
de à côté arrête un peu si si si il est
il est très présent à la London clinique
est hospitalisé clque London quoi en
fait c'est la clinique de tu dis la
clinique London clinique on dirait que
tu as dit un nom de ouf ouais comm si tu
dis je suis à la c'est vrai comme si je
suis à combo clinique c'est la clinique
de Londes c'est vrai c'est surtout
peut-être la clinique la plus chiic dere
c'est un peu un hôtel particulier de
grand luxe qui est médicalisé si vous
voulez bien avec des plats étoilés avec
des chambres qui font de 40 à 80 m car
avec votre propre médecin qui ne vous su
qui ne vous quitte pratiquement pas
jacuzzi dans la salle de
basère tu CIS
vraiment AC les faire
jacuzzi mais le gars il est com C JAC
C il est de doigs passerarm à gauche
Fame un jacuzzi qu un jacuzzi c'est une
baignoire avec des bulles là qui vous
Perm ah bah merci on savait oui oui oui
on
savait je t'enfire des bulles moi carré
pour la petite histoire sachez que JFK
et Elizabeth tlor ont été soignés là-bas
aussi croyais qu'ils étent encore
vivant ils sont morts ils sont morts oui
mais ils ont été soignés là-bas en tout
cas pour vous dire à quel point cette
clinique comment dire ils on sont morts
tu peux pas nous sortir des gens vivants
qui ont été soignés là-bas il y en a
aussi y a aussi non mais c'est ils nous
sont sorti deux morts ça donne pas envie
et lorsque Auguste pinchet éta arrêté il
était à la clinique à la London clinique
enfin bon bref on s'en fout tu es venu
pour donner un cour d'histoire pour mais
mais alors justement j'arrive au vrai au
problème vous savez c'est que depuis ce
matin et bien la il y a pas que kê à la
London phenque il y a également Charles
I Charles a été à nuit ce matin aussi à
la clinique et lui il a on pense bien
qu'à l'URE qu'il est il est déjà opéré
il a été opéré non d'une
hypertrophie les
oreilles frère le BA il est comm parleur
par direct non je l'aime bien tu sais
que je kiffe Charles moi tu me regardes
comme si non non je te crois prostate
sur prostate la prostate prostate Alain
prostate
excellent Formule 1 ou hyper trophite la
prostate hyper trophie il faisait plus
pipi correctement donc c'est pas la
peine
de un peu de respect quand même
correctement il c'est n'importe quoi il
arrivé
il tu fou quoi non mais attends
calme-toi quandme c'est le roi ouais
donc tu dis non mais c'est vrai il paraî
que le flux aurait fortement
diminué
intervenir ah merde non mais c'est vrai
que quand tu commences à en avoir sur la
S c'est que c'est pas
bon alors oui d'autres choses ou donc
c'est une hypertrophie bénigne de la
prostate donc c'est pas très grave et
c'est une intervention que la majorité
des hommes qui ont 75 ans ont déjà subi
on sait queilà les problèmes de la
prostate chez les hommes c'est quelque
chose de courant ah ouais donc c'est
rien ils vont lui remettre un bail c'est
pas très grave donc il va faire pipi
correctement dans combien de temps
là ça je sais pas on pense bien que dans
le courant de la semaine prochaine
Charles devrait déjà sortir et kê aussi
d'ailleurs puisque kê ça fera donc 14
jours dans le courant de la semaine
prochaine mais la le problème c'est que
puisque Charles vous l'avez compris est
à l'hôpital K est à l'hôpital William
est à son chevet ben il y a plus grand
monde pour euh pour assurer voilà pour
régner il y a un peu une vacance du du
trône comme dit et dans ces cas-là le
protocole nous dit que ce sont les
conseillers d'État qui doivent reprendre
la relève à savoir bah normalement ce
sont c'est l'épouse du souvrin donc
c'est Camilla qui devrait bosser mais
elle est au chevet elle aussi de Charles
donc c'est Anne la sœur de Charles voilà
la princesse Anne qui ne cesse pour
l'instant de remettre des décorations
des médailles voilà voilà Anne pour
l'instant la monarchie repose c'est pas
un mauvais délire on dirait Géraldine
dans 40
ans
décon c'est un truc de ouf attends c'est
bon tu reconnuit pas
incognito 10
ans on l'appelle la princesse royale l'
royale ouais bah nous on et et voilà bah
c'est Anne quoi elle manque peut-être un
peu de glamour parfois pour le job tu Mo
l'impression qu'elle est sympa mais il y
a pas vraiment de vacances mais quand on
a un problème de prostate on passe
beaucoup de temps sur le trône en
principe non ah
ou
[Applaudissements]
s'en fout de tout lui alors qu'est-ce
que tu as d'autre que voilà c'est déjà
pas mal non Anne hier et bien dans l' de
la remise des décorations elle a reçu
Stephen freze
vousz elle l'
fait non le le
réalisateur réalisateur ven il est venu
avec
non
on a fait un chevalier voilà il est
désormais chevalier on l'appellera donc
sort Stepen ouais qu'est-ce qu'il y a
Bertran c'est quoi l'état d'esprit des
Anglais est-ce qu'ils croient à ce qu'on
leur diten alors il y a un bruit qui
s'élève quand même en Angleterre et qui
nous disent que autant le palais de
Buckingham a communiqué d'emblé et nous
a dit pour le roi il s'agit d'un
problème de prostate et le roi
d'ailleurs a communiqué en disant je je
comment dire j'invite tous les hommes
qui ont un problème de prostate à aller
consulter pour qu'il plus de
autant du côté de Kensington Palace donc
de Kate et William on ne parle pas et le
fait de ne pas parler a tous les bruits
qui circulent et on dit ça aurait pu
être une modernité aussi en quelque
sorte de la part de Kate Middleton de
dire j'accepte voilà je joue la
transparence et en tant que princesse de
gale j'accepte de livrer mon dossier
médical même si on le sait ils ne sont
pas obligés de le faire même le
souverain n'est pas obligé de rendre son
dossier méd parce que c'est pas très
princesse de parler de son utérus en
même temps voilà c'est un peu le
problème vous imaginez Mo quand elle va
recommencer à aller serrer des mains et
couper des rubans elle va peut-être
tomber sur une dame qui va lui dire oh
moi aussi je me suis fait retirer
l'utérus qu'est-ce que ça fait mal c'est
peut-être un peu gênant donc voilà on
pense vraiment que que c'est plutôt ça
qui pousse le pet voilà mais Charles et
la prostate est-ce que c'est aussi
plus glamour oui est-ce qu' Harry se
manifeste ou est-ce qu'il s'en fout
complètement j'ai lu qu'il était en
vacances à la Jamaïque ça me semble
insensé en vacances à la Jamaïque
absolument c'est pas qu'il s'en fout
c'est que à nouveau il paraît que le le
Palais a tellement dû nous ditons
communiquer vite lorsqu'ils ont appris
l'intervention du roi que il était 4h du
matin euh aux USA en Californie lorsque
Harry l'a appris donc il l'a pris par
les médias au petit-déjeuner en se
levant le matin donc à nouveau il y a
encore du ressentiment qui dit mais de
toute façon on a pas besoin de moi donc
c'est pas très grave en plus la prostate
enfin en plus pour le coup c'est pas
très grave tu traverses pas le monde
pour aller voir ton père qui s'est fait
faire un touchou alors actuelle
l'Angleterre a surtout part pour k
middle attende attende quce que vouses
direavers qu'est-ce que tu as dit
travers pas l'Atlantique pour aller voir
son père qui vient de se faire un touch
rectal en fait j'ai dit ça mais c'est
vrai mais c'est ce qui s passé
mais vousêtes de dire que le roi
d'anglre c'est ça en fait c'est
bénés
pasavion pour d'Ès ce que
j'ai
déjàra pas
VO
examenam pass une sorte de caméra
l'intérieur du fion pour regarder un peu
partoutm on le
film il avait pas de caméra c'est direct
le
Doig déjà de la
télé longs donc tu es arrivé chez le
gars il t'as vu
[Rires]
reconnais mais vous savez qu'il faut le
faire à partir de 50
an mais c'était il y a 2 3 ans je vais y
retourner à partir de 50 ans il faut le
faire tu doour combi temps 3 ans faut
que retourne je vais retourner la
semaine prochaine semaine prochaine sa
que tu vas
venir fais gaffe qu'il oublie pas le
gant vous devez savoir ça vous avec
vosre grande connaissance de médecine sa
trop
jeunetoi e dis-moi dis-moi alors non
dernière chose parce que tu sais que
j'ai j'ai d'autres sujets quand même
ouii je sais tu es sympa toi on peut
parler de ta carrière ou pas du tout de
moi oui si tu veux oui
SALUT vous savez qu'il a plein de
propositions en ce moment voilà alors ah
ben non pas du tout ah d'accord très
bien merci c'est triste ouiou bah tu
m'as dit oui mais ils ont dit non ils
ont dit non merde je peux le dire ou pas
bah oui vas-y proposé de faire les
traîtres sur M6 ah éit trop bien ah
ouais et alors et au final qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé tu as été viré mais ils
m'ont pas rappelé la attends peut-être
qu'ils vont te rappeler ou mais il te
connaissais d'où à mon avis de toi bah
oui ouis donc eu tranquille il viennent
nous piquer les gars tranquille M6 alors
qu'il nous donne même pas une image
alors qu'il parle même pas de nous sur
le r je vais m'en occuper de ce week6
vous allez voir c'est pas 66 minutes qui
vont prendre dans la gueule c'est bien
plus vous comprenez pourquoi ça ne se
fera pas je t'avais dit oui en plus oui
c'est vrai bah oui je peux plomber un de
leur
programme toujours un bon camarade he je
en ai mis M po de balade je sais j'en
l'urais mis oui mais je les aime bien al
mais comment ils t'ont appelé il t' dit
est-ce que tu voudrais faire traître
ouis voilà c'est ça et toi tu as dit oui
toi ou te demande d'ê traître tu dis oui
oui ça m'amusait ou alors mais qui t'a
demandé un gars t'a appelé une fille que
je connais pas moi qui par SMS oui
est-ce que ça vous intéresserait d'être
un tra absolument vous savez moi je
demandé à C non tuas un amour toi il m'a
demandé non mais lui lui non mais alors
je voudrais dire ber je l'aime
mer mon chéri quoi c'est là qui t'ont
pas rappelé alors je t'explique Cyril
c'est vol de mort pour les chaînes non
mais je te le dis non mais attends il
faut jamais prononcer mon nom tu as mis
que mon prénom ou tu as mis cyil Anouna
mais non c'était par téléphone tu as dit
cyil Anouna mais ils m'ont dit a pas de
souci on comprend obtenz l'accord de
Cyril on et après quand tu as dit que tu
avais l'accord B non ils ont pas RA
attends c'est peutêtre pas qu'il-être
qu'ils ont pas fini le casting attends
minutes pas des fétises comme ça il
serait bien dans Bienvenue au monastère
ouis c'est il serait bien chez lui
aussi tu veux faire bienvenue au
monastère
serait chamb non franchement c'est vrai
il faut qu'il m'appelle non mais plus de
chance qu'
t'app là il vont ils vont
t'appeler à côté de ton téléphone merci
la productr formidable Chantal tu vas
l'adorer tu es chaud pour faire
bienvenue au monastère pourquoi pas tout
faire toi non pas tout faire mais c'est
ce que c'est tu sais ce que c'est bien
mon oui j'ai vu ou d'accord bon tu sais
où tu es là oui oui merci onrouve dans à
tout de
suite